ci sono le robe e con robbie intendo
giochi e con giochi intendo cose che ho
fatto negli anni che si discostano
insomma dai giochi normalità le perle
quelle robe che non si dimenticherà mai
sei voli sulla mia lapide voglio scritto
turbo dismount un giorno allora mi fa
strada ridere il fatto che abbiano fatto
uscire un aggiornamento con un'ambulanza
c'è una macchina nuova cos'è veramente
dopo tutto sto tempo ha fatto uscire un
aggiornamento va bene siamo ragazzi sul
turbo nisba un anche chiamato
motivazione per la quale non ho la
patente esattamente per questo motivo
turbo dismount ragazzi ti permette di
fare che come spiega renato zero
c'è veramente di partire con le macchine
ed intestare ok la già ecco perché
andato storto ci sarà un motivo
tu hai un percorso da seguire è ok e in
questo percorso devi di riuscire a farti
più danno possibile teoricamente questo
sarebbe l'obiettivo del gioco poi ecco
non so se si è capito ma è niente altro
la videocamera non rimane attaccata la
alla macchina come che è successo a roma
a camera si arrivi a ecco perfetto
avevamo no
perfetto ma attenzione marco demonio
sto gioco incredibile ragazzi allora
fatemi fare fatemi fare i miei livelli
però fatemi testare manuela eccola hanno
fatto veramente l'ambulanza va dai
immagino che una cosa sia rimanere
dentro sulla barella
credo ecco figura se tu puoi fare il
morto
di tutto questo puoi fare il morto che è
bellissimo ma neanche se ci riprovo
finisco così bene al centro della mappa
frigo è la mia preferita in assoluto
perché ti fai di un male perché passano
le macchine furti si è fatta di lego c'è
va dai ho fatto fatah e va dai raga non
ha senso
ho fatto un saltino se small e colata in
aria non è un vero veicolo scomparire
quasi quali sono l'altro le altre cose
12 all'altra rimane attaccato dietro
ok che potrebbe avere un consenso è però
ha apposto molto bene tutto ok
tutto questo e turbo di smau ma cosa
recente tipo ecco esattamente ragazzi mi
sembra il modo migliore per farla finita
questo guardalo sono riusciti a beccare
niente incredibile loot box cioè se
finito e se finisco lì c'è una route box
cos'era loot box ci sarà colpisco cosa
succede scusatemi
può non ho capito ma va bene è successo
qualcosa è però ho capito cosa sto gioco
incredibile ma devi provare il divano il
divano e il perché io ho comprato sto
gioco la prima volta ci voleva che roba
è bellissimo marca puzza si è salvato un
cuscino in tutto questo va bene vedere
se c'è il carrello che il carrello è
un'altra già solo lui il carrello
installa il jaeger madonna dimentica
cos'è cos'è è una roba sexy teoricamente
dovrebbe essere questo va bene dopo io
non me ne sono altamente sbattuto di
tutto non mi è andata neanche troppo
male incredibile ma mi sa che ci sono
alcune rope che non ho mai fatto
potrebbe essere tra ente ciao col
jamboree sulla sulla tavola per lo zio
bravo non riuscirà a cadere molto prima
perché se credo molto prima facevo una
sciata di quelle potenti e poteva
accadere l'asta macchina guarda guarda
come scia potente bellissimo media un
round tipo giorno che potrebbe avere un
senso c'è l'importante e staccarsi dalla
macchina e proseguire sciando può essere
quella buona attenzione se non mi avesse
peccato la macchina grazie grazie a
scaramanga mammamia questo era un casino
perché sta qua devi riuscire ad
atterrare in piedi dalla nova questa
impossibile ragazzi in 20mila volte ci
ho provato non ci sono ormai parte ci
sono riuscito una volta sola se tu devi
atterrare dall'altra parte dritto
l'impossibile parte che con alcune
macchine tipo questa non puoi neanche
farlo
e così ha già un senso però dovresti
atterrare sul caso è quello però vabbè
andiamo così grazie mi hanno donato in
super chat a caso perché in questo
momento sono in live con di chi c'è io
sto registrano questa cosa e poi vado in
live con di chi no perché la mattina che
faccio le live ragazzi partecipate alle
6 di mattina che sono bellissime
tra poco vado a raggiungere nichi e gli
han dorato cicolari chat vinili niente
grazie ragazzi devo cambiare macchina
non so non ho idea di quale macchina
possa fare questa cosa ve lo giuro
perché proprio una roba storta un'idea
[Musica]
mi sa non questa c'è un modo regione una
volta sono uscito
eccolo ok può andare molto più lento
tipo centrato lentissimo è esatto esatto
esatto no vabbè
ok bedini farlo più piano teoricamente
dovresti riuscì teoricamente ma ancora
molto più piano di mente va bene madonna
ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi ho trovato
basta farlo così in più lento tensione
cielo
[Musica]
proprio lui ho parcheggiato storto che
l'ho ce l'ho fatta sta macchina è
bellissima
voglio provare vedere se riesco a fare
una roba con la ecco la mega ramp ad
esempio questa macchina potrebbero un
senso perché è veramente troppo potente
però devi mettermi iturbi smentito il
milan voglio vedere due va da fini se
faccio mi turbi al massimo porca vacca
oddio sperduti è bellissima sfida che mi
è venuta fermi un attimo poi provare a
vedere che succede se figlio il cosa a
rovescio
ma va bene lo stesso vai molto più lento
zia e perché purtroppo il turco vi frega
[Musica]
ho capito ma ha vissuto non farla la
rampa se fa schifo porca vacca come
faccio con la prego il brad pitt
[Musica]
questa è la presa tensione è tutto come
dovrebbe andare ai ragazzi per carità
siamo ritornati all'inizio perfetto va
bene allora puoi provare col senza
questo affare quindi senza questo caso
mette il turbo anche qua turbo lag
madonna che macchina bellissima tra
l'altro sembra quelli cda normalmente
dovrebbe fare l'autore bene anche
scalarlo suo muro però per a non si può
che derivare alla fine si assicuri ok
ottimo parcheggio se prendo il turbo al
massimo eccolo forse stavolta rientro
dai ragazzi
devi andare devi andare vai vai vai e
arrivare alla fine impossibile porca
vacca non ci riesco dove prendeva con lo
scooter non ce la faccio
full field ok e la madonna un po meno
madonna che schifo che stava lentissima
ai proviamoci
e invece
non è vero per un metro la come anzi un
centimetro perché questa voce un sacco
di aderenza ecco perfetto full speed
praticamente adesso ci dovrà essere
riuscito solo ed unicamente perché
questa c'è più aderenza dai vai dritta a
port code ma veramente per un metro
labbra o forse ce lo fa questa volta sì
mio zio è stato veramente è
difficilissimo però incredibile ce l'ho
fatta con una macchina ci avrei mai
messo un euro questa macchina
incredibile fantastico ma non c'è niente
solo quella destra lui va a destra ma da
ora c'è un masochista
va bene va bene ok bellissimo vado via
da te all'altra fa ok monorail in
silenzio cos'è sta roba già se questa
non me la ricordo ad evocare il treno
che mi viene addosso non lo scrivono
scapito assi il treno viene addosso
periodo tentare di intercettarlo piano
che vediamo rai porco demonio
eccola eccola eccolo proprio certa che
tecniche questo non lo fanno non te lo
fanno studiare all'esame di guida me lo
dico io ragazzi questo era turbo lisma è
bello liszt è ritornato alla seriamente
ogni tanto ciò queste in questi film die
riproviamoci almeno un episodio che mi
piace sta roba fatemi sapere se siete
d'accordo possono ve ne frega niente
cioè a me piagni giuro sono proprio il
primo primo fan del tempo quindi dico
cavolo vorrei veramente di ritornare ai
tempi era bellissimo vero vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi iscritti al canale
schiacciate la campanina con la
bellissima che ho detto i 106 scriviti e
noi come sempre ci vediamo a un prossimo
video l ragazzi
[Musica]